I think the lack of accountability is  leading to so much unhappiness  like life is so much better when you're  like this was my fault yeah absolutely  you're in control yeah and so like you  know this was like a wrap up to control  you're in control you you you decide  what you consume you decide what you  believe you decide who you surround  yourself with you decide what you put  out take on accountability yeah  everybody wants to blame right now the  algorithm they're acting as the  algorithms are like hypnosis and I  understand endorphin hits and all that  but like you can delete the app  you can  like where's accountability in this